[Musica]
ciao
questo è perché siamo professionali
nella vita e nell'anima solo perché
abbiamo 5 milioni iscritti quando avevo
un milione faceva vede un po a caso
adesso c'è uno che prima dei video mi fa
così quindi ragazzi siamo tornati su un
altro episodio di unboxing ed oggi
rispetto alle altre edizioni di unboxing
abbiamo una scatola un po diversa che il
nostro uomo ci farà presente tra 32
grazie uomo allora le scatole in pien
di solito nelle unboxing sono fatte di
cartone che è quella roba marroncino con
scritto unboxing fa vj questa sembra una
scatola di scarpe quindi poi ci sono
delle scarpe e dico belle poi ha finito
il video oppure non ci sono delle scarpe
va bene direi che possiamo iniziare
questo nuovo bisogno di un box i pali j
scartata però non lo possono anche
scattare le parole forbici min ed
evitare lo stesso perché è prassi quindi
direi che possiamo apprestarci adam
boxare questa scatola fantastica
[Musica]
mi rifiuto
no perché ogni volta robe del genere
perché allora la cosa molto bella è che
ogni volta che apre una scatola trovo le
cose del genere non sono mai troppo
contento però non fa niente allora nella
scatola di oggi abbiamo dei dolci
giapponesi la faccenda è che l'ultima
volta che ho mangiato roba giapponese
non è stata proprio il proprio il
massimo prodotta si tratta di dolci è
veramente figo è bellissima c'è giuro
che non ho mai sono una scatola così
colorata allora mushroom shaved
chocolate biscuit funghi con la barba a
chi cioccolato bene no bellissima sta
roba ho capito dopo allora devi fare
devi creare delle formine di cioccolato
e puoi mangiarti bellissimo o bollito
dell'acqua già un miracolo che non sia
esplosa la casa ma perché è stata non lo
bollita io dovrei infilare questo affare
qua dentro
così in teoria si dovrebbe sciogliere
spero perché sennò siamo nella cacca
questa roba qua come funziona la metti
dopo che la metteva dentro
prendi uno di questi cosi se si riescono
ad aprire prima che si solidifichi prima
che si solidifichi so prendi lo metti
dentro la cremina quelli ragazzi mentre
aspettiamo che è la nostra cremina con i
suoi comodi si solidifichi direi che
possiamo passare al next tablet kennis
quindi sono semplicemente delle mentine
non lo so i giapponesi usano le menti
beh considerando il cibo giapponese
devono avere delle mentine tante perché
faceva veramente schifo quindi secondo
me ha senso che ci siano queste mente mi
sembra un po il vicinato e quello del
vate però spero non abbia lo stesso
sapore mentine giapponesi le slot sono
buonissime buonissime cgt spacchi la
mascella per un perché un enorme però
siamo veramente buono allora ci sono
tante cose che mi ispirano soprattutto
questa credo su centrino dei kiwi poi
non ne sono sicuro allora abbiamo
segue chimica mi kendra mele gommose al
kiwi
chiudiamo questo anno questa fedeli
giapponesi che aprì le buste e dentro le
buste ci sono altre multe l'odore della
carta è buonissimo andiamo all'acciaio
non mi sarei aspettato di certo una
caramella diversa da questa l'odore è
dolcissimo allora sarà di kiwi e cioè
quel retrogusto di kiwi però è proprio
un è una caramella gommosa kiwi direi di
buttarci ragazzi su una cosa un
pochettino diverse andiamo a sulle vedo
che sono distanziate l'una dall'altra
però ci sono dei kit kat
al gusto il gusto uva e il kit kat al
gusto
non so che cosa sia sembra ramen ok
proviamo quello bussola per primo ma
spiegami araba e ripieno dietista roma
nonché saliti sembrava twitter
normalissimo come fa sapere di uva come
hanno fatto a metterci cosa dell'uva
mentre il kit kat è buonissimo
questo però non temono questo seriamente
paura di mangiarlo ragazzi no come
prossimo direi di aprire il gas successo
quando sono dati giappone era pieno di
così così veramente cioè io mi sarei
mangiato tutto anche il negozio però che
non sia perga di cosa potrebbe essere un
problema però sembrano sono zampe di
gatto zampe di gatto al gusto un'uva
cioè voi non mangiate le zampe dei
vostri gatti ma può essere veramente
direi di andare sul prossimo
la cosa molto divertente che sono tanto
che finora abbiano solo mangiato ma non
abbiamo bevuto
quindi direi di buttarci su no non è
davvero e scherzato prova da pirlo ma
non di cosa sia queste sono le cose che
mangiano comunque i bambini giappone se
le mangiano loro e non succede niente
non so bene che sapore ha però sono di
gomma in questo non è ma vengo io credo
che sappiano di limone
non so faccio schifo ma capire i gusti
comunque potrei mangiare tipo alla
carbonara spacciarla per nutella ma
allora the next ed è il più grosso di
tutti proprio ci stava ma la pena nella
scatola non so come hanno fatto a farlo
stare
e questo che sono dei pancake alla crema
di fagioli
ok io sono già stati giapponesi già
mangiati so come sono fanno vomitare
morso grande è uguale a mangiarlo tutto
il morso grande va bene fa schifo regala
siamo lì fagioli mi avvio sembra tipo
marmellata visto antella oppure
marmellata scaduta da mesi pro e crema
di fagioli e fa schifo mi fa vomitare
possono mangiarla nata mangia mi spiego
questa particolarità di queste cose
fantastiche si chiamano d'ora gli ati
d'ora in un si chiama d'ora in non
perché mangia sempre questi cosi d'ora
gli atti c'è solo un modo per mangiare
questa roba
ed è chiudere gli occhi maledetto
moralismo è la prossima prelibatezza
direi di andare su una cosa che mi
ispira tantissimo tra queste che questa
boccetta di m dovrei far montare anche
la rassegna pavimento
ah sì queste bellissime chest ma si sa
sono rimasti agli ultimi 5 dolci direi
di iniziare con questo che tra tutti
quanti quello che mi ha sempre tirato di
più di tutta questa scatola
però non ho ancora provato si tratta di
sushi con modo il sushi gommoso a maggio
devi preparare siccome cioè che li
dovete fidare sulla parola non si
capisce veramente niente le istruzioni
che ci sono dietro
ricordiamo un tutorial su youtube perché
è infatti bill è così ok questi di
spostiamo un secondo
allora di fianco a questi qua facciamo
l'operazione c'è anche la beretta
ibx slater abbiamo finito ci ho messo un
sacco però considerando che sulla
scatola il risultato sarebbe
dovuto essere questo qui alla fine siamo
più o meno riusciti a giungere ad una
conclusione
direi che a questo punto non ci rimane
che assaggiare la nostra prelibatezza
appetito sushi gommoso compratelo anche
voi che vi assicura tre giorni vi mal di
stomaco e altri tre consecutivi di
riabilitazione
sembra una figurina d'oro di quelle del
povero toro g energy va bene proviamo
no però ok nextreme allora tra tutte
queste ce n'è una in particolare che non
ho mai capito di tutta la scatola che è
questa che sono sembrano delle dei
chewing gum di pikachu che non è male
proviamo a vedere sono bellissimi forati
i colori fantastico coca cola loro vivo
già mai doma fu più dura nella mia vita
e con la coca cola che il muro per tv
come penultima prelibatezza ho
adocchiato dall'inizio questi che anche
un capitolo fosse smith and he used pil
quindi sono scorze di limone dolciastre
in realtà ha un odore veramente orribile
sapone per i piatti partito
no non mangiate il sapone per i gatti fa
schifo direi che con questo possiamo
giungere all'ultima pietanza di oggi che
sono lello panda sono delle caramelle a
forma di pancia c'è un disegno del panda
sopra le conoscevo già perché sono
malato io vado a cercarmi dolci
giapponesi su internet e le conoscevo
già
adesso le prove per voi ma so già che
sono abbastanza buone vedete disegnino
del panda come è fatto bene e poi
rilassamento e così però altrochè i
vivai panda ragazzi abbiamo concluso
tutto per oggi sono una cosa
all'inizio del video abbiamo visto che
si potevano creare questi ombrellini
adesso il momento della verità o la va o
lavora perché lo fatti c'era messi da
parte sono signora freddati cavoli oro
la salute è veramente buono logici o
lega parli ecco se vuoi fare una cosa
fatta bene fatta da solo quindi in
conclusione se vi è piaciuto se vi piace
il giappone e i dolci di oppone la chat
e mi piace a velo
io ringrazio per questo scatto la
fantastica speriamo che nella prossima
ci siano un po meno schifezze anche
perché io non ho più una somma quello
con questo video ragazzi 6 video è
piaciuto lasciate un commento mi piace
anche ai soci ad ottenere iniziare se
non c'è d'amore ci siete vi e noi ci
teniamo video questo buon tè che non c'è
facessero per fare scena volevo dirvi
che in queste vacanze visto che sono
molto rilassato in questo momento non so
se si nota dal mio taglio shopper le
volevo dirvi che ho fatto un regalo a
jacopo il ragazzino bambino il supereroe
con cui ho registrato la prova non
ridere challenge di qualche giorno fa vi
ho fatto un regalo e volevo metterlo
alla fine di unboxing perché alla fine
anche lui ha fatto questo unboxing
quindi a boxing di jacopo a fine video è
più grosso ditte hanno le scatole
adesso poi adesso possono notare quanto
manca natale ma sì che tenendo lega sono
sintomi che cos'è chi ha detto e mi
ricordano scorsi del ventilato forno
amara ma tant'è spagna ha mercato cioè
un mchardy non enorme
hai visto ti piace sono contento e
comodi si stima che ho diversi
lorenzo austin propria univideo visto
che tu lo sai vari nell'occhio limiti in
francese
[Musica]